einen schönen guten morgen aus berlin
der bundestag debattiert in dieser
ersten sitzungswoche in diesem jahr vor
allem über die vorhaben der
ampelkoalition in der nächsten
legislatur und es ist schon eine
besonderheit in zu beginn einer
legislatur und in dieser woche dass
wirklich jede ministerin und jeder
minister einmal vor dem bundestag
spricht das sind dann immer so eine art
mini regierungserklärung und dann folgt
immer eine aussprache zum jeweiligen
ressort da gibt es schon mal die
möglichkeit einzelne punkte aus dem
koalitionsvertrag anzusprechen schon
einige akzente zu setzen und die
opposition kommt natürlich auch mit
ihrer ersten kritik schon zu wort das
meiste haben wir in dieser woche schon
gesehen vier ministerien stehen noch aus
die im laufe des tages hier im bundestag
auf der tagesordnung stehen und
jeweiligen ministerinnen und minister
sprechen werden das ist verteidigung
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung ernährung und landwirtschaft
und um 9 uhr da warten wir den auftritt
von bundesfinanzminister christian
lindner und eine debatte zum thema
haushalt und finanzen und da steckt doch
einiges an konfliktpotenzial drin denn
zum jahresbeginn da gab es gleich
negativ schlagzeilen für eines der
ersten projekte von christian linder und
zwar für den nachtragsetat
2021 den hat der bundesrechnungshof
gerade als verfassungsrechtlich
zweifelhaft gerückt darüber müssen wir
natürlich sprechen und auch über das was
christian lindner mutmaßlich in seinem
ersten jahr als finanzminister noch
beschäftigen wird und ich freue mich
dass deswegen bevor sie im plenarsaal
losgeht zwei gäste zu mir gekommen sind
und ich darf sie herzlich begrüßen das
ist einmal janine wissler die co
parteivorsitzende der linken aber heute
morgen vor allem auch da als mitglied
des finanzausschusses und otto fricke
darf ich begrüßen für die fdp fraktion
der haushaltspolitische sprecher ja herr
fricke die ampelkoalition christian
lindner hat im dezember noch fix ein
nachtragshaushalt auf den weg gebracht
60 milliarden euro nicht genutzte corona
kredite das soll jetzt verschoben werden
in einem nebenhaushalt in den energie
und klimafonds um in zukunft damit
klimaschutzmaßnahmen zu finanzieren das
wird von der opposition hier harsch
kritisiert auch vom bundesrechnungshof
unter anderem man muss man fragen gerade
die liberalen haben das immer kritisiert
corona corona kredite
um reserven zu schaffen ich kann die
zitate aus vergangenen debatten gar
nicht aufzählen von fdp-abgeordneten von
liberalen die das immer kritisiert haben
auch neben haushalte zu schaffen warum
gilt es eigentlich nicht mehr wenn die
fdp nach 55 jahren den finanzminister
stellt und sie in der regierungssitzung
wenn es erstens so wäre dass man einen
neben neuen nebenhaushalt schaffen würde
wir nehmen aber einen existierenden mit
klaren regeln und zweitens und das ist
sehr sehr wichtig wenn es so wäre dass
das geld einfach nur hingeschoben würde
dann wäre nämlich genau der effekt
entstanden man nimmt irgendwelche
reserven aber es bringt nichts für das
was wir in der wirtschaft im moment
erleben ein investitionsstau für das was
viele ökonomen inzwischen als long kurve
in der wirtschaft bezeichnet und
deswegen haben wir als fdp auch wert
darauf gelegt dass ich nicht einfach nur
in so einem dummen jährlich kites
prinzip denken nach dem motto okay wenn
ich bis dezember nicht ausgegeben habe
ist es weg sondern wo will ich mit der
planung hin zweitens und das ist dann
eben sehr sehr wichtig deswegen ist bei
der frage wie das geld ausgegeben werden
kann und bis wann das geld ausgegeben
werden kann klar kurz und mittelfristig
kite gesagt wir müssen das in der
nächsten zeit machen das sorgt dafür
dass jetzt mit diesem beschluss
industrie wirtschaft aber auch bürger
die ja auch da stark entlastet werden
vor allen dingen die geringverdiener
wissen dass sie an bestimmten stellen
nicht zusätzliche sondern weniger
ausgaben haben wenn das gerade in dem
moment wo wir steigende energiepreise
haben von großer wichtigkeit ist und
deswegen ist das richtig kritik kann ich
verstehen kann ich auch nachvollziehen
aber es in dieser situation eine aufgabe
von politik dafür zu sorgen dass klar
ist wo nächstes jahr die reise hingeht
und nicht zu warten bis wir im mai dann
einen haushalt 22 haben denn wir haben
jetzt erstmal die so genannte vorläufige
haushaltsführung wenn sie das inhaltlich
so begründen ja aber es geht ja auch um
die glaubwürdigkeit
beispielsweise auch von christian
lindner und da muss ich ihn schon noch
mal vorhalten dass er ja auch an seinen
eigenen aussagen gemessen wird er hat
erst im oktober in einer zdf sendung
gesagt wenn man wegen der korona
pandemie eröffnete kreditermächtigungen
nutzt um gewissermaßen einen vorrat
anzulegen für eine neue koalition dann
wäre das nicht seriös richtig wenn es
einfach wäre völlig richtig eigentlich
was ist noch ein vorrat was ist das wäre
es einfacher wäre es dann wenn du sagst
da ist das geld wir tun dass man ihn mal
gucken was wir damit machen was aber oft
jetzt nicht gesehen wird ist was der
haushaltsausschuss in seiner sitzung am
mittwoch zu der frage der verwendung der
gelder gesagt hat erstens gesagt kurz
und mittelfristig und zweitens gesagt
wofür es überhaupt benutzen kann und das
sehr eng und sehr klar eingegrenzt um
klar zu machen was müssen wir machen und
das ist die aufgabe die wir jetzt schon
hier jetzt am anfang des jahres nutzen
um für das laufende jahr klar zu machen
für industrie fiel wirtschaft aber auch
für den bürger wo die reise hingeht frau
wissler herr fricke hat gesagt das geld
entlastet ja auch die bürger allerdings
die linke sagt erstens christian linder
umgeht damit mit diesem
nachtragshaushalt den bundestag und
diese 60 milliarden würden grad sagt die
linke auf dem rücken der kleinen und
mittleren einkommen ausgetragen ist es
mich ein bisschen einfacher schluss also
wie kommen sie darauf erst mal finde ich
ganz interessant wenn das weltbild der
fdp auf die wirklichkeit trifft dass es
nicht zusammenpasst und christian
lindner als finanzminister schon in den
ersten wochen über seine eigene
ideologie stolpert weil im wahlkampf
wurde gesagt keine steuererhöhungen und
gleichzeitig einhaltung der
schuldenbremse und jetzt ist natürlich
die situation dass man sieht man braucht
investitionen wenn man modernisieren
will wenn man in die zukunft investieren
will klimaschutz andere maßnahmen da
muss man geld ausgeben und deswegen ist
das jetzt natürlich eine umgehung der
schuldenbremse wir sind durchaus der
meinung dass wir höhere investitionen
brauchen auf jeden fall aber wie man der
meinung wir brauchen dafür eine andere
steuerpolitik und wir sollten die
schuldenbremse grundsätzlich infrage
stellen weil zu sagen die schuldenbremse
gilt keine andere steuerpolitik aber
daneben sondervermögen zu schaffen die
dann eben am parlament vorbei
bitte getätigt werden das ist natürlich
ein problem ich will noch mal auf den
punkt kommen deswegen habe ich auch weil
ihn noch mal nachgefragt diese 60
milliarden es ist kommt ja für den
bürger jetzt darauf an sie können das so
zu sagen natürlich technisch
haushalterisch begründen es kommt für
den bürger darauf an nutzt es ihm das
jetzt etwas und er nutzt es ihm nichts
und die linke sagt ja es belastet er
mittlere und kleinere einkommen ist das
wirklich so ja es ist grundsätzlich
richtig dass mehr geld in energie und
klimaschutz investiert wird
selbstverständlich aber natürlich ist es
notwendig zu einer umverteilung zu
kommen weil im moment erleben wir ja
gerade dass gerade auch die kosten der
energiewende die kosten des
klimaschutzes umgelegt werden eben auf
die menschen mit geringen und mittleren
einkommen und wir sind der meinung dass
die lasten
für diesen umbau der industrie eben vor
allem die tragen müssen die in den
letzten jahren gut verdient haben und
natürlich ist es so dass wenn man sagt
man will mehr geld investieren aber
nicht bereit ist die höheren einkommen
und die hohen vermögen in diesem land
stärker zu belasten dass es dann immer
eine ungleichheit ist so eine soziale
unausgewogenheit von daher jahre
brauchen sehr viel höhere investitionen
dazu muss es möglich sein eben auch sich
zu verschulden aber wir brauchen auch
eine andere steuerpolitik um diese
kosten zu tragen und da geht es um
klimaschutz um investitionen werden der
korona krise gesehen gerade im bereich
der pflege brauchen wir dringend höhere
mittel und auch in vielen anderen
bereichen und dafür brauchen wir um
verteilung herr fricke
ich deute ihre mimik so lange jetzt noch
mal auf diese 60 milliarden ja das sind
schulden die von letzten jahr in dieses
jahr verschoben während der ermächtigung
noch sind es keine schulden deswegen
sage ich auch ausdrücklich es sollen
auch schulden werden bastian aber ich
muss eine sache von whistler ich hatte
immer gedacht das kommt hier nur von
einer fraktion so was am parlament
vorbei und so weiter um das mal klar
auch für die wirklich sagt die union
aber dass die aber schon hessen genau
wissen ich hab sie doch
frau kollegin wissler ich habe sie noch
aus denn erstens wir beschließen dass im
haushaltsausschuss nach einer anhörung
an der ihre fraktion auch teilgenommen
hat es werden alle details besprochen
alle vorlagen liegen vor es wird nächste
woche im plenum besprochen alle vorlagen
liegen vor dann kommt der energie- und
klimafonds dessen geschäftsführung auch
vom bundestag beschlossen wird sie
können kritisieren dass ihnen der weg
nicht gefällt aber es ist doch schon ein
widerspruch zu sagen ich bin gegen die
schuldenbremse und dann auf der anderen
seite aber zu sagen aber ich will doch
wieder an der stelle das geld ausgegeben
und schließlich und das ist mir jetzt
wichtig bei der pflege zu behaupten
werden da nichts getan diese koalition
hat also eine erste maßnahmen
zusätzliche eine milliarde für die
pflegeversicherung gegeben vom
steuerzahler an alle zu versichernden an
alle schwachen zweitens und wenn sie
sich den punkt angeguckt hätten jetzt
von dem von dem nachtragshaushalt ist
ein ganz wesentlicher punkt die
absenkung und am ende vollständige
absenkung der eeg umlage wem hilft dir
am meisten denjenigen bei dem strom an
den täglichen ausgaben den höchsten
anteil hat den schwächsten unserer
gesellschaft den erbsen unserer
gesellschaft und das muss man einfach
auf sagen dann kann man anderes
kritisieren aber bitte bei den fakten
gleich frau bisher ich will noch mal
darauf zurückkommen in der tat sehr früh
gesagt ist am montag gab es eine
expertenanhörung herr fricke man muss
auch dazu sagen die ökonomen und
juristen sind sehr gespaltene ansicht
was diesen nachtragshaushalt anbelangt
dort ist aber tatsächlich schon ein
bisschen vor gebaut worden falls das
ganze doch vom bundesverfassungsgericht
landet und man hat sozusagen die
verwendung der mittel zweckgebunden und
auch gesagt das muss in der nächsten
zeit schon passieren das heißt man hat
es an energieeffizienz beispielsweise im
gebäudebereich gebunden überzeugt sie
das und ändert das ihre meinung dass die
mittel ja sozusagen wirklich jetzt
zweckgebunden und auch zur überwindung
der cobit pandemie so steht es auch in
diesem beschluss drin verwendet werden
ja normal also wir sind dafür dass es
höhere investitionen gibt kritisieren
den weg und ich will sie drei ihrer
nehmen dass die fdp in hessen zum
beispiel genau gegen ein solches
sondervermögen dort der schwarz grünen
landesregierung geklagt hat genau mit
dem argument dass es ein sondervermögen
ist das eben nicht nur wie jetzt corona
kosten decken soll sondern eben auch in
andere bereiche investiert wird obwohl
dort natürlich auch der
haushaltsausschuss natürlich involviert
war und natürlich auch dort beschlüsse
mit getroffen hat also von daher ja wir
brauchen höhere investitionen aber es
zeigt er die ganze crux wir brauchen
also statt das geld aus dem laufenden
haushalt zu nehmen und das ist natürlich
das recht des parlaments geben jährlich
den haushalt zu beschließen macht man
jetzt mit dem energie und klimafonds ein
sondervermögen das jetzt auf das dann ab
vermutlich verwendet wird benutzt dafür
die kreditermächtigung aus dem letzten
jahr und das ist aber natürlich auch
total kurzfristig gedacht aber das ist
ja eigentlich ein eingeständnis dass
eben der bund nicht genug einnahmen hat
und nicht genug mittel hat um die
dringend notwendigen investitionen zu
tätigen und jetzt versucht man eben
diese pandemie situation zu nutzen und
wir sagen wir brauchen dauerhaft höhere
investitionen und da reicht das
natürlich auch nicht eine milliarde in
die pflege wir wissen was mit enormen
ich sage es reicht nicht wir haben
enormen mangel an pflegekräften das
wissen sie wir haben pflegenotstand wir
haben viele investitionen in die
krankenhäuser wir haben das problem dass
in gender finanzen die da jetzt hier um
die es da geht und deswegen wenn wir uns
die immensen kosten anschauen dann ist
das würde ich sagen die achillesferse
der ampel also dass eben die core das
was sie eigentlich vorhaben überhaupt
nicht ausfinanziert ist der
nachtragshaushalt soll ende januar dann
hier durch das parlament verabschiedet
werden mit der mehrheit der
ampelkoalition die unionsfraktion hat
angekündigt dass sie damit vors
bundesverfassungsgericht gehen wird wir
werden also sehen wie das ganze ausgeht
ich möchte noch zu einem anderen thema
kommen christian lindner wollte
anscheinend auch gute nachrichten zum
jahresanfang verkünden und er hat große
taten angekündigt 30 milliarden
steuerentlastungen für die bürgerinnen
und bürger und auch für die unternehmen
allerdings wenn man sich mal anschaut
auf den zweiten blick 30 milliarden sind
eigentlich auf vier jahre gerechnet gar
nicht so viel das sind dann pro jahr
7,5 milliarden und darunter fällt
beispielsweise die absetzbarkeit der
rentenversicherungsbeiträge das ist aber
eh von gerichten vorgegeben und die
abschaffung der eeg umlage auf die
strompreise ab 2023
das wird aber durch die co2 preis quasi
wieder aufgefressen
tatsächlich wie viel entlastungen von
diesen 30 milliarden kommt überhaupt
beim bürger an sophie kann das auch gar
nicht sie werden vollständig ankommen
bei der eeg-umlage deswegen weiß ich ja
noch mal daraufhin und kollegen wissen
ich würde mal empfehlen mit der von mir
sehr geschätzten kollegen löschen ein
bisschen über haushaltsfragen und die
frage wie das im bund ist zu reden da
waren so viele sachen wo ich einfach
sagen es stimmt nicht zweitens diese 30
milliarden sind die die jetzt feststehen
die aufgabe von guter haushalts und
finanzpolitik es zu sagen was geht jetzt
schon was ist jetzt schon klar und das
machen wir gerade beim thema
absetzbarkeit von rente wo es ein urteil
gegeben hat dass ich so oder so hätte
reparieren können dann das reparieren
wir so dass wir möglichst alles davon
absetzen können bei der eeg-umlage und
der frage der co2 abgaben ist es ja
nicht so dass diese co2 abgaben dann
einfach so im staatssäckel bleiben
sondern auch ja wieder zurückgeben denn
da kommen wir in die frage der
kindergrundsicherung wir werden hier
noch einiges an entlastungen erleben so
das sind die 30 die jetzt schon klar
sind und die zeigen wir in der
perspektive auch auf aber alles andere
sage ich immer ist die frage wie gehst
du mit der feststellung einer
notsituation das wird ja oft vergessen
indem wir uns ökonomisch finden um und
machst eine planung die zeigt wo es
hingeht aber vorher schon etwas zu
versprechen
bevor wir nicht den haushalt 22 im mai
haben und bevor wir nicht im november
den haushalt für 23 haben ist falsch die
30 sind erster guter schritt und das ist
das was man zeigen will wo wir diese
regierung hin wenn sie die möglichkeit
hat die bürger machen sich sorgen wegen
explodierenden gaspreisen und
zunehmender steigender inflation diese
versprochene entlastung von christian
lender wie viel kommt ihrer ansicht nach
beim bürger an ich glaube es kommt vor
allem bei denen dies dringend brauchen
sehr wenig an und an der stelle will ich
sagen können sich ihre belehrungen und
auch ganz gerne schenken ich meine sie
haben im wahlkampf alles ernstes
versprochen 90 milliarden entlastungen
ja jetzt merken sie dass das natürlich
alles überhaupt nicht funktioniert das
haben experten experten aus forschung
gesagt und diese 30 milliarden wo das
ist ja keine entlassungen geben dir bei
denen ankommt die besonders jetzt leiden
unter den hohen energiepreisen deswegen
sagen wir wir brauchen dringend für die
niedrigen einkommen insbesondere für die
menschen im hartz iv-bezug und dass es
nicht nur steuerliche maßnahmen sondern
da brauchen wir dringend einen aufschlag
auf die sozialleistungen dass das
dringend notwendig und zwar nicht erst
im frühjahr sondern jetzt sofort also
nicht nach dem gießkannenprinzip sondern
wirklich gezielt und direkte hilfe für
die menschen die es am dringendsten
brauchen dass es sehr viel sinnvoller
dass das eben das geld dort direkt
ankommt und natürlich müssen wir auch
schauen wie man das hinbekommt dass die
strompreise die gaspreise nicht immer
weiter explodieren und dazu brauchen wir
auch den ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien das ist ganz wichtig weil das
ist die technologie die am ende den
energiepreis senkt und nicht verteuert
nun ist es allerdings so frau wisse dass
tatsächlich es gibt eine studie des
zentrums für europäische
wirtschaftsforschung die sagt dass sogar
kleine einkommen also um unter 20.000
euro profitieren von ampel vorhaben
nämlich zwölf euro mindestlohn und die
kindergrundsicherung also ein bisschen
entlassung kommt auch bei den unteren
einkommensklassen an oder das ist
richtig die zwölf euro mindestlohn das
ist ein schritt in die richtige richtung
wir haben das gefordert von daher ist
das richtig dass notwendig dass das
jetzt schnell umgesetzt wird aber wir
müssen natürlich auch an die menschen
denken die im hartz iv-bezug sind da
habe ich von der ampel noch nichts
konkretes gehört also es reicht ja nicht
dass man hartz 4 ein bürgergeld
umbenennt man muss natürlich an den
regelsätzen etwas verändern die müssen
sofort deutlich erhöht werden und
grundsätzlich das ganze hartz iv system
in dieser form abgeschafft und komplett
überarbeitet werden das ist dringend
notwendig aber man muss auch sagen 12
euro mindestlohn ist immer noch nicht
existenzsichernd für viele von der 12
uhr mindestlohn schritt nach vorne aber
wir müssen die tarifverträge stärken wir
müssen dafür sorgen dass menschen
grundsätzlich besser verdienen und von
ihrem lohn leben können erfolg ich hätte
sie gern noch gefragt was im moment das
rezept ist gegen steigende energiepreise
aber vielleicht hören wir da in der
debatte einiges vielen dank dass ihr und
morgen da waren janine wissler für die
linke und otto fricke von der fdp denn
es geht training los ich sehe wolfgang
kubicki der bundestags-vizepräsident hat
den plenarsaal betreten und wir schauen
mal rein